welcome back while the Conservatives
weren't the only party to pick a new
leader this week and the Lib Dems new
leader J Swenson joins us now from
Glasgow hello to you I give ridings if
he good to be with you I could see that
you were watching intently and along to
that Jeremy Corbyn interview so first up
what did you make of what he said well I
think he's pretty hopeless and I think
there's millions of people across the
country who are crying out for
leadership for opposition to Boris
Johnson and to brexit and they are not
getting it from Jeremy Corbyn in his
rule as leader of the Opposition I mean
he didn't even say whether he would
oppose a Boris Briggs that deal he said
well maybe see see what he comes back
with whether or not we're gonna well
they're not gonna like Boris's breaks it
and you know he's already you know
failed the test of holding Boris to
account by refusing to call no
confidence in his government so you know
Jeremy Corbyn is bottling it he can't
make up his mind even now or where he
stands and as Liberal Democrat leader
well I have to I have to take the place
and you know provide the real opposition
that our country needs I guess what
Jeremy Corbyn would say to that is that
he is trying to do the right thing he's
trying to unite people who voted in
different ways in the referendum you of
course have ruled out any kind of pact
with Jeremy Corbyn now we know of course
that Boris Johnson is prepared to take
us out without a deal on October 31st if
there's an election before that are you
really saying you wouldn't team up with
Jeremy Corbyn even if it was to try and
stop a no do brexit I'm gonna be if
there's a general election arguing that
we need a proper alternative to both
Boris Johnson and Jeremy Corbyn that can
paint a vision of hope for our country
and where the task is to stop brakes
that stop Boris and start renewing our
country
that's what we need to deliver and
that's what your interview with Jeremy
Corbyn proved just now that he is in no
position and no appetite to be able to
do so it's the Liberal Democrats who
will fight on that ground and I'm
determined to fight and win
congratulations with battling with the
noise are from their aeroplanes are very
valiantly there and are you having talks
with conservative MPs about defecting to
the Lib Dems
that I have talks with MPs from
different parties we're working together
on the people's vote campaign to stop
breaks it and indeed I've had
conversations with people who are
understandably very unhappy in their
current parties when you've got the
Conservatives going off far to the right
chasing Nigel Faraj and you've got
labour going off to the hard left and
we've already seen sugar emunah join the
Liberal Democrats and hopeful that there
will be more MPs joining the Liberal
Democrats but you'll appreciate why
those private conversations have to stay
private if they're to be effective and
the Sunday Times is reporting that you
were even dangling the bubble of seats
in the House of Lords if people defect
the Lib Dems it's not really democratic
well that's certainly news to me and not
the way in which I don't the way in
which I operate so I would I would take
that one with a hefty chunk of salt okay
and now I'm keen to just ask you about
something you said earlier this week
when you're asked if you would vote to
implement BRIC said if people voted for
it for the second time in another
referendum and you said no you said I'm
not going to change my view on what I
think is right for our country doesn't
that make an absolute mockery of the
campaign to hold a second referendum if
you're just gonna make nor the result
why don't you just be honest and say you
want to campaign to revoke article 50
what I was asked is whether I would
agree with leaving the EU and think that
was the best for our country and
obviously I'm not gonna suddenly change
my view but I think if we had a
situation where we had a people's vote
on a specific break set then if there
were to be a vote in that scenario in
favor of a specific regs that deal then
I would absolutely recognize that that
was what the country had decided to do
at the moment the difference is and the
difficulty is is that I don't think
there is a majority in this country for
any specific type of breaks it even the
brig's the tears can't agree among
themselves some of them say that trees
amaze deal is not good enough because
it's not brexit enough for them and
others who voted leave in good
conscience listening to what they were
told about how they would be leaving
with a deal in an orderly manner or
uphold at the thought that we might be
crashing out without a deal so there was
an agreement amongst brexit ears
therefore I don't think there is
agreement in the country for any
specific brigs that proposal and that's
why we need to put this issue back to
the people in a people's vote and I will
campaign strongly with the Liberal
Democrats to remain in the EU but just
be really clear we know you'd campaign
to remain in a another vote but would
you wanted there were any result of a
second referendum yes I wouldn't stop
changing my view about what was right
for the country but yes I would
absolutely order that result okay and if
we do leave in October as Boris Johnson
once would you then campaign to rejoin
the European Union well first of all and
determined to stop brexit but in the
scenario that we end up outside of the
European Union we need to recognize that
that's not the end of breaks that that's
the beginning of years and years and
years of brexit negotiations and
wrangling you know this is not going
away from our TV screens anytime soon if
we do leave the European Union and in
that scenario there's going to be
decisions day in day out week in week
out about what our relationship looks
like with the European Union and I will
be campaigning and arguing for as close
a possible relationship of those
circumstances for regulations to align
as much as possible for us beefing up
our diplomatic efforts in EU capitals so
that we have strong relationships
because that is where are our best
future lies as members of the European
Union and if it cannot be then it needs
to be as close as possible to the
European Union for a strategic
geopolitical interests and for people's
jobs in this country here's more of
conversations about breaks I'm sure our
viewers will be delighted
that prospect now of course you were
elected as leader the Lib Dems this week
or just wanna have a little look at your
voting record when you apart with the
government under the coalition at that
time you voted for the bedroom tax you
voted for the introduction of universal
credit you vote in favor of scrapping
the educational Maintenance Allowance
and favored increasing tuition fees and
also capping increases and benefits
below inflation is that a voting record
that you're proud of
well I've already said that there's
things in there that you've read out
that I think that we got wrong and that
we need to learn from those errors and
that we shouldn't have for example let
the bedroom tax go through there's a lot
of good that we did in coalition helping
children from the poorest backgrounds
with more money in schools introducing
same-sex marriage taking people a low
pay out of having to pay income tax but
equally we didn't get everything right
and so I you know I think that we do
need to reflect on what we would do
differently and learn those lessons in a
speech and a couple of years ago you
said that the Lib Dems must own the
failures of your time in coalition and
that we should have done more to stop
policies such as a bedroom taxes you
know just talking about there should you
personally have done more well I think
all of us need to consider that and and
yes I mean I was you know in government
there's a lot of things that I fought
for and won battles like on gender pay
gap reporting that the Tories didn't
want to do on making sure we were able
to clamp down on payday lenders which
Tories didn't want to do but there was
also battles that I fought and lost in
government so against employment
tribunal fees was an example of that so
you know this those cases where we
fought and we lost those cases where we
fought and won and of course I look back
and you know I think there's there's you
know we have to reflect and say yeah
there's probably areas where I wish I'd
done that differently because you're
always making in a judgement and an
analysis of how winnable is this fight
and and therefore can it you know will
it will it work and I don't I think I
look back and of course
things that I regret just finally and
we're all very clear of course where the
lib dems stand when it comes to a brexit
what you what what do you fall
other than braixen well I think our
country is at a moment where we do need
transformation
I think our economy is fundamentally
broken in the way that it works or more
accurately doesn't work for people
living in poverty and for our planet
when we are facing a climate emergency
so I think we need to reshape our
economy so that it works in the long
term for people and planet and that's
partly about the relationship between
business and society it's partly about
how financial incentives work in the
capital markets for example there's a
lot of change that our country
absolutely needs if we're gonna have the
positive future that we want of course
leaving the European Union makes all of
that harder because we will have less
money to deal with things and we will
have less influence around the world but
whatever the resolution of that we need
transformation within our country okay
Jo Swenson thanks very much for coming
on the program today